hey guys I'm Alanna I'm Cassidy I'm Jen
and today we are playing Silent Hill PT
yes do it there we go okay all right
really nice look at that place that you
would you know I would I probably
wouldn't I wouldn't my drink over there
no I read a book it already scares me oh
no watch out the gap in the door it's a
separate reality you know I wonder if
that is supposed to mean that like when
you open the bathroom door mm-hmm you're
opening like a separate reality cuz does
she come phone in I think she does I
think she does either
this is definitely how it starts it's
just the one bug I chose it later
oh you don't have a torch it either
alike yeah see we call it torch torch
yes I see bonus icy poles cute I'm
supposed um are you straight back and
forth we don't use that word either
really several days before the house
neighbor sings
yeah this radio yeah said he was
changing
state last month I mean to send a
message a blue skittles main use of
rifle and meat cleaver to murder his
entire family in each case the
perpetrators were father's say please
say the student domestic homicides
appear as part of a larger trend such as
employment childcare and other social
issues I don't think you can do anything
first-timer yeah so in a game like from
when I played it I really remember the
order of anything
I don't remember I just know that I see
a lot of things you just know like hate
it yeah yep okay look the same moment
the floor wet no it's a sort of no I
think it's just shiny
should I look at this plant now god I
hate this game
not yet I think it's a sort of personal
yeah still 23:59 always the lights are
on
oh yeah you someone has a torch yet I
think you maybe get that in the bathroom
I don't remember I'm glad I don't
remember cuz this is new again
mmm new and horrible see that one's
closed now there ya hear that yeah
mm-hmm hear it that's a banana should
you can you go no not yet it has to be
like a crack in the door it surrounds it
on headphone oh yeah that would be some
freaky [ __ ] you're talking to the game
like it's the dog anything you looking
up that makes me freak out it's so much
loo no it's fine it's fine with my mojo
at all the other door yeah I'm just like
a look at it a bit more I think faster
yes
I think
there's something we're missing out on
yeah I'm not sure yeah I just I love it
unless you don't know her yeah how did
do things um to finish the game last
time I definitely had to look [ __ ] up
cuz I was like well see I looked stuff
up but didn't end up finishing it with
any of the stuff that I looked up yeah
but I didn't start looking stuff up
until like I was completely yeah I was
like sitting like I was doing Mesa River
yeah this is not a game that I don't
think or that I think I could ever play
by myself no I have only acquainted with
other people like wait that was on the
wall yeah that was in the wall with
NASA's r3 maybe if I mean was like it
falling off yeah maybe yeah okay now
it's open I don't remember that
okay you're good Jenny good Jenny you
okay great I'm only friends because I've
played this I'm not brave at all I know
I mean I'm not that brave but since I
played this before I'm okay with
controlling it otherwise I would make
someone else control yeah I think I'm
okay with controlling it but I just
don't feel really nervous right now
I'm just like a deer in headlights with
things like this you know I react the
same way when reactive mental life was
just perfect oh yeah is that what you
would do if you were in this hallway
right now probably I probably would just
shrink into a corner and hide there yeah
I'm like a really shitty cat knocking in
the bathroom again
oh that's the pictures in the pot plant
oh yeah if you just go around to us Oh
got it
let's get me yeah oh wait there's more
of it right yeah yeah you put it
together yeah yeah you're putting it
together sorry
it's spoiling this I don't remember they
all either I forgot already
I remember there was one like up in the
corner of something like you have to
look above yeah mm-hmm sounds right but
I don't think you can do it all on this
go around like you have to go around a
couple times alright I'm not sure I
think there's birthing any change
there's one in the menu if you go to
options yeah it's your options menu like
go to options
it's supposed to be it's in here
somewhere hmm I don't see anything
yeah maybe it's not there yet just you
like even looking at the end of this
whole way makes me like yeah I have no
idea hi I'm so brave right now oh look
it's a bug
it's my breathing you're out like are
you nauseous who are you scared because
yeah I don't know what I'm feeling right
[ __ ] me hold on I don't know what I hate
it it's not a possum majestic oh it's
just a car gesture just to coat every
once in a while actually at least yeah
yeah and a little freaky then yeah I
think so yeah yeah is it there yet yeah
where if you have to get a listen you've
got it yeah you look like gibberish
Italian oh my god the shadows
everything is awful I don't like want to
walk through here sometimes as the
lighting where is bad wrist hockey bag
yeah I'll talk to a bag I'll talk to a
bag
I'll talk to admit I'm getting
progressively more scared but it's funny
because like when you stop this just
nothing really happens yeah and it's
still the pictures coming together yeah
I don't remember where they will bother
I really don't I just remember yeah that
one up in the corner I remembered
yeah it is Oh yep got it see what is
that Stuber ish yeah I don't know if
that says anything they're really small
it's very all right
like I really couldn't find some of them
when I was playing my first time just a
zooming in on paintings hello thank you
cuz I got in the corner maybe I know
there's one on this Destin your
Everywhere's nope
it might not be that yet like I don't
know if they all show up at the same
time yeah just you turning around yeah
it's true dude straight okay Oh goodbye
why what have I not done well it wanted
you to see that yeah was it raining it
was yeah it's always raining wants me to
cry look at the dust the radio is on
this probably piece on that or like me
in there or something the leaf
it's makes me so nervous more it goes
along yeah I'm switching off with you
soon you know bathroom door bathroom
door door oh [ __ ] I don't want to bugs
oh I don't want to I don't want to
laying the good bits employer gets to on
top scary
that was coming so I look slightly away
from screen down your shirt